gun violence kills hundreds of nevadans
every year and now in an interview that
you'll only see here on eight news now
democratic congressman stephen horsford
is using his own story to push for
change
his father died in a shooting nearly
three decades ago now the congressman
hoping a new piece of legislation will
prevent
other families from experiencing similar
trauma
in an exclusive interview he's telling
his story to the i-team's david charns
someone chose violence and took his life
that doesn't have to be it's a moment
congressman stephen horsford says
made him passionate for change we're
talking about breaking
the cycle of violence so that no one
has to experience it a cycle of violence
that's affected his own family
starting when he was 19. it was trauma
for all of us for our entire family you
know i've
again tried to turn that pain into a
sense of purpose
in 1992 a gunman shot and killed
horsford's father
at this north las vegas convenience
store your dad is dead
okay what am i supposed to do with that
that's 28 years ago
i am now in a position where i can do
something about that
he's introduced the break the cycle of
violence act which creates
community-based intervention programs
you don't give them anything else to do
what do you want them
to do targeting young people at risk
teenagers like sean jerion coleman
i feel like if you get on the face
you'll change then
what are you doing coleman survived a
shooting two years ago
now he too is turning that scar
into new found self-confidence it's a
chance to
be the change you want to see that's
what i always say he's the president
of an advisory council here at nevada
partners
i was on the streets at 16 17. so it's
kind of like being in the streets you
know
you just learn you know you either adapt
or you die this is a poem for brianna
taylor i wrote we fought long and hard
in protest and campaigned to get your
killers arraigned but he's adapted in a
different way it's hard to explain why
another innocent black individual has to
be slain
taking up poetry writing a new chapter
one in his life in other lives too they
plug you into programs and
they put you they set you up with people
that could really help you move into a
path where you want to go
i didn't have the opportunity for my dad
to see me graduate from college
for him to see me get married for my
three kids to
have the chance to to to meet
their grandfather for the congressman
it's about investing
in another way to reduce crime and to
prevent one's potential
from being stolen my job is to try to
give somebody else
an opportunity he didn't have a trauma
that i
experienced that my family experienced
the too many family members
in throughout southern nevada and and i
i'd never want my community to be
labeled as
as violent democratic congresswoman dina
titus is a co-sponsor of the bill as are
48 other members of congress all of them
democrats
right now the bill is making its way
through two congressional committees
i'm david charns 8 news now a recent
government report finds gun violence
cost our country more than 200
billion dollars a year that's about 700
dollars for every american now as david
mentioned
no republicans have signed on to that
proposal we did reach out to the
national republican party for comment
and they declined